climate change
has a new poster boy companies from
british airways to facebook
and pop artists like billy eilish and
massive attack
have promised to make changes to bring
their greenhouse gas emissions
closer to net zero they're joining a
club of more than 50 countries around
the world
this race to zero is a vital step
towards managing climate change
but what does net zero really mean and
is achieving it
even possible
[Music]
net zero has gone viral
but like all simple slogans the reality
of achieving it
is far more complicated
humans burning fossil fuels has resulted
in more carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
which is warming the planet
[Music]
to stop the warming the level of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere has
to stop rising
[Music]
the obvious way to do that is to stop
emitting them
but that's easier said than done for
some industries such as aviation and
manufacturing
eliminating emissions is really hard
in the years leading up to the
copenhagen climate conference in 2009
scientists realized something it wasn't
possible to cut emissions fast and
thoroughly enough
to meet the temperature targets that
policy makers wanted
what was needed was to actively remove
greenhouse gases from the atmosphere too
people began to talk about a world in
which greenhouse gas emissions and
greenhouse gas removals
balanced each other out so that the
overall effect
was net zero
the countries that signed up to the
paris agreement pledged to turn
this idea into reality by agreeing to
balance their emissions and removal of
greenhouse gases in the second half of
the century
to achieve net zero emissions we need to
do two things
one which is more obvious is to cut our
output of greenhouse gas emissions from
things like burning fossil fuels
but the other is actually to take
emissions out of the air and that's the
harder and
sometimes more obscure aspect of getting
to net zero
this is known as negative emissions and
the scale on which they might be
required is one reason that net zero
targets will be hard to achieve
we'll need to go from a world economy
that pumps out on the order of 40
billion tons of co2 a year
to one that sucks down that is removes
billions of tons per year in the future
to get to that net zero future
there's different ways to do this
forests do this naturally
through biological processes or sinks
but what
we're really looking at now to achieve
ambitious climate targets
are man-made approaches
some methods for removing greenhouse
gases from the atmosphere are already
being used at scale
such as the planting of new forests and
improving soil
so it can store more carbon
but there are new technologies at a much
earlier stage of development
among them ways of capturing carbon
dioxide and storing it underground
carbon dioxide could be poured directly
from the air by machines
or by growing plants burning them to
generate electricity
and then capturing the carbon dioxide as
they burn
there's a flurry of innovation in
negative emissions technologies
a range of ambitious to wacky
and none of them are proven at scale and
that's what makes them so problematic
the world is counting on innovations
that have not yet been demonstrated at
scale
to achieve targets that we're setting
for ourselves and that's a big question
mark
we're hopeful but it is still a risky
bet
how much greenhouse gas needs to be
removed from the atmosphere
will depend on how much emissions can be
cut
the conundrum that is we need both
massive reductions in emissions as well
as a dramatic scale up and proving
of the technologies for negative
emissions
there is a tension between the two and
it's easy for governments and industries
to kick the can down the road
saying well let's go a little slower on
the cutting of emissions now
which will be better for the economy or
for our profits because we can always
make
massive negative emissions reductions
later when
innovation makes those technologies
cheaper and better
the dirty little secret in that argument
is that it may come too late
and it may well give permission for
polluters to get away with polluting
much more than need be
rather than innovating ways to reduce
emissions now
there's also the question of who takes
responsibility for each molecule of
greenhouse gas
one of the most difficult challenges is
that lots of
countries and companies and individuals
don't want to own up to their carbon
footprint
for example carbon intensive countries
like india china other emerging markets
that are producing enormous amounts of
emissions today
they point out that the goods they
produce for example may be consumed by
americans or europeans
so they should do the negative emissions
or they may say
rich countries got rich putting carbon
dioxide into the air
now it's our turn to lift our people out
of poverty so you pay for the negative
emissions
as yet there is no universal policy for
accounting for and attributing emissions
today
governmental net zero pledges cover over
two thirds of the global economy
america and the eu are working towards a
target of net zero by 2050
and president xi of china the world's
largest emitter
has pledged to achieve carbon neutrality
before 2060.
some people see ambitious climate
targets and say fantastic
the problem's getting solved here's the
problem
a target is no guarantee that we're
going to get to the goal
it's important to have targets it binds
society together
it gives you a direction in which policy
is going to go it gives investors and
markets
some idea and some degree of certainty
as to what investments to make
however we often fall short of targets
also we should remember
most government policies focus on
cutting emissions rather than how to
tackle negative emissions
embracing enacting and scaling a
negative emissions plan to get to
net zero is a herculean task
this is something far bigger than say
the moon shot or
other initiatives that it's often
compared to because this involves
really every economy on earth every
government
ultimately every citizen all of us have
to be involved
and change the way we live and it's not
just a technological revolution
we need a revolution in our mindsets
i'm vijay vadis warren the economist
global energy
and climate innovation editor to keep up
to date with all of our climate change
coverage
please click on the link thanks for
watching
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]